it was the lure of the ancient ruins of
Machu Picchu that drew 28 year old
American Zachary MEK straw to Peru in
mid-march so this is our room there are
six of us in this room but for the last
three weeks he's been under a military
enforced quarantine inside a cusco
hostel where two occupants tested
positive for the corona virus we feel
like hostages you know we are on daily
calls with the US Embassy but we just
seen action he says the US government
has not been able to get him in six
other Americans out we've all received
four patreon fights to leave and we're
all being threatened with the other five
ten years prison or we are being
threatened to be shot three Americans
tried to leave a few days ago and a
police officer pulled a gun on that the
US State Department says it's brought
home 31,000 Americans from 72 countries
but the process has been criticized as
being slow and disorganized those who
returned never imagined long planned
vacations ending on government chartered
flights anybody was prepared for this
situation at all at one point never
expected to really be able to get home
so it was a real roller coaster of
emotions 69 year old Vietnam War veteran
Raymundo Jacques is in route home from
Ecuador
he says his children had to beg the US
Embassy for help feeling like that
no abandoned the second time of my life
country not good al Jazeera spoke with a
total of seven stranded Americans - said
as the US has become the world's hotspot
now staying away feels safer but then it
kind of came down to not really wanting
to go back to the US when the virus is
kind of taken over and it seems like
things are kind of under control for now
in Nepal most though say they continue
trying to return home with a US
government's help but to no avail it's
just me and my daughter and I need to be
there but I don't know seems like it
doesn't count and they fear time is
against them hi Joe Castro al Jazeera
Washington